[Music]
hello and welcome to sidetrack again
hello live
for another video
before we get into everything else you
did that little opening sequence there
matt for us uh i i'm gonna say two one i
love the little
bit at the end i'd love that
but all the way through it i'm flashing
back to my and i'm i'm a little bit
older than you i feel but i'm flashing
back to my commodore 64 on nintendo nes
days with the music
you know what the hardest part of doing
that was finding music that actually
goes
i was like i was on all these
royalty-free websites like
just give me something it needs to be
like nine seconds long just give me
something and that was one i found and
then the thing at the end 1980s i love
the ding you message me and you go i
like the ding and i'm like oh i'm gonna
do something with that and then i made a
little glare as well which was
absolutely stunning so we are here
because we are going to hello again
everybody getting into the chat thank
you very much but we are here again
today because
i'm
very lazy
um as you all if anybody that knows and
loves me will know
um i'm not but i do have a full-time job
i also have a family
um that love me and apparently want to
spend time with me don't understand it
i'm a grumpy old sod so i know i don't
think they want to leave me alone but i
do struggle to keep up with the with the
channel the way i'd like or or i end up
making videos that aren't as good as
they could be because i'm rushed
and i did for some reason decide to do a
live video and two videos a week don't
know why i decided to do that matt um it
seemed a poor decision but it's crazy
it was ridiculous
so
all hail matt who has come in to save
the channel and to allow us to take it
to next level because we went through 10
000 subscribers a hell of an achievement
um you know we've i'm not even going
here yet hell of an achievement but we
do want to take the channel to the next
level and that next level requires a
little bit more quality unless maybe
quantity so well except we're gonna have
the same quantity so i forgot i said
that um but to do that matt has worked
really hard this week and he has created
us a new opening sequence which i adore
um we have created a new channel psytrek
clips which um is going to have little
clips from the live videos so you can
bite size into them so please go and
find that channel and subscribe if you
haven't already um but also what we're
going to do is matt is actually going to
be jumping in
and doing a few videos with us and just
before matt says anything because matt
you know you're only to speak when
spoken to
if you don't follow that joke is because
it's something i said last week that
that late that week in that video right
i edited that video to put it on the
clips channel right and i made a joke
because you started to say something i
should have matched up matt speaker
spoken to but then i could go on to
speak for like three minutes
i look like such when you originally
messaged me that you said
you you misspelled um show and you put
up you put shirt
yeah i just thought you were making a
shut up matcha
like five minutes and i was like oh no
i think i might have to put a show at my
shirt
[Laughter]
but very quickly here is a little sneak
peek of what you can expect and we'll
tell you exactly what matt's going to be
doing with us
[Music]
fact three don't mess with amanda
tapping ever hello everyone my name is
matt you may have seen me on the live
show as i do with jay aka sidetrack and
i will be making some videos on this
channel moving forward a slap across the
face
i wonder which male scientist that would
have been i mean this didn't happen but
imagi i can imagine it being rodney
mckay if he's going to deliver a
powerful monologue why would he be there
with a microphone like can you just
imagine an episode of stargate where
they're all sitting there with
microphones like colonel there's a
different jafar coming just imagining
richard d hansen now with long hair and
a beard welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi
tv and movie channel
seeing someone with
my little sci-fi trek and tv channel
better than i do is really annoying i
didn't know whether or not to do it and
i was just thought
[Laughter]
part of the brand no sister now you have
to oh we have to get you a sidetracked
t-shirt as well
um because it's the brand and now you
are part of the thing so basically what
we're saying here is that matt is
joining the side track channel the
family and you're going to be doing
videos on a tuesday for us hopefully
every tuesday um
uh if ever it's a tuesday it's because
matt couldn't be bothered
so if you might be afraid from the
tuesday because
um the first video is only loaded up
it's set up as a premiere i please guys
set your reminders it's going to be
tuesday at 6 00 p.m um it is a genuinely
brilliant um video it makes me realize i
need to improve my editing skills but
because of this i've got more time to do
that and time is a precious gift matthew
so um and i appreciate it um
and you know it's just like this is why
i wanted to do this channel as well
because i wanted to meet other people i
wanted to you know i've just done a
video with harris and stormy somebody i
met both those guys met through the
channel i would never have met him
otherwise
matt you're the same even though you
actually live horrifyingly close to me
but that's not why we've done this i
know i really
that realization
we'll have to actually meet at some
point which is just not right i'm saying
you should be youtube friends i'll just
be like oh my god
you're real
exactly i won't be wearing a sidetracked
t-shirt you won't recognize me you just
walk very happy
um
yeah so yeah so yeah basically that's
what we're doing guys um matt is going
to be doing our tuesday videos the first
video is about five
facts created by an ai they're genuinely
very funny um it was it was made
um
on a
this was before i i was going to make a
video
i i like the idea of artificial
intelligence so i was looking at like
gpt3 and all all the things that come
with it and then found this website
and i was just i was just
messing about basically and i just typed
in stargate facts
and then it goes
pick uh pick an opening i was like okay
i'll pick that one and then go to pick
something else okay i'll pick that one
and then i'll start reading these facts
and i'm like
these aren't true are they
these didn't happen i'm gonna i'm gonna
make this into something so i made it
into a blog post which i then shared on
facebook and then
got turned into a video maybe video
soon
you're a video man don't want it do it
okay
um
but then i guess so
yeah i i i'm really happy to have you on
board um i say i suggested you do a
video you dead in a brilliant video so
which all led to this um
making it make sure that i got a little
bit more time on my hands so i can
hopefully try to create
a videos to your standard um but don't
forget whose channel it is
and that you are my [ __ ] okay i mean i
don't i don't even think my editing is
that great to be fair
it's just a good video take the
compliment
if you okay please they're all going to
go downhill from here you know that
right if you could that'd be great
just watch what i do and emulate that
standard and know better that would be
great okay
no but
seriously that it's it's it's about
taking and doing the best thing we can
do for the lovely people that watch
our stupid little videos
um so as always guys if you have ideas
that you want matt to explore
um you are a whovian as well which i
think is fair to saying i'm not so you
will be doing videos on that
um
[Music]
anything you guys want us to talk about
in the videos though please do we'll do
little shared videos still and things
and we'll do live videos and stuff but i
really want to announce this because i
think it is worth
it's a big it's a big day for the
channel basically
it's going to be it's a it's a complete
change about
when the video comes on and tuesday
you'll see why i'm so excited because
it's it's it's actually good he can
actually string more than two words
together which i genuinely a lot of the
time can't
can i or could i just edit it well
enough so you think i can
see some of your editing you do struggle
more than four words
i put three of them i'm the king of the
king of the jump cut
yeah well i say i'm not so i
it's funny though i like doing these
videos i mean people watch these videos
and a lot of people will quickly jump on
and um have a go at me particularly for
only your editing oh this oh you made a
mistake in that video and they don't
appreciate it it's actually quite hard
to point a camera at your face and talk
um it's not the easiest thing in the
world so i've run out of water which is
also a problem
um
it's it's doing these videos it's hard
you know and it does take quite a lot of
time and i've got
reasonably good at it and that when i
make a mistake i know to stop myself i
pause for a second and then i just
repeat and i've got quite good which
helps with the editing
and so i've got better at that it's took
me four years to get better at that but
i've got a little bit better at it
and but every so often you can see when
i get excited about this topic i'm
talking
yeah and then i have to i have to cut it
and it does sometimes it works sometimes
it doesn't but you just go with it
sometimes you have to cut out whole
sections and just so it'll jump like i'm
sure he was talking about that minute
ago right no i wasn't
i've had to cut out like three minutes
where i just
oh sometimes because i don't like
scripting so my way of doing it is um
harris is with the host whoop
he's
he's a good-looking boy i don't like him
um
so
and what's the same so um i don't like
to script them myself i write notes
obviously and i prepare what i'm going
to talk about but i don't like scripting
i like to just riff a little bit and
then sometimes i'll i'll do it two or
three times and like edit in the best
bits together so that that's how i
prefer to work if i scripted it it would
just be boring i wouldn't i wouldn't
enjoy it so much
even though it probably didn't make a
video i've tried scripting before
and
it does it's very hard
if you're not used to it to deliver a
line and have it be
authentic
so i i'm very much like you i will just
speak to the camera and i will ramble
for half an hour and then i will make
something out of that edit it down to a
three minute video
i i i think i think it makes a more
fluid video i do get the odd comments
sort of occasionally like for the love
of god script
because you just because i will you have
an idea that other than the worst is
when you have an idea halfway through
video
and you think in that moment this is a
great idea
and then you talk yourself down a black
hole
[Laughter]
i don't know where i was going with that
but then you've got to edit that out and
edit it back oh
it's hard man it's hard but now i only
have to do one video a week because
matt's going to do another video so
come on
really important day i'm really i'm
really happy to have you on board
i'm happy to be here very excited for
the future it's going to be good yeah
well that's the thing we've got a nice
little a nice little show that we're
going to turn into um
a nice slightly bigger show and we'll
see here we go
but thank you for joining us tonight
alex i just wanted to announce this i
wanted to tell the world or the couple
of hundred people who watch this video
that this is what we're gonna be doing
and please like i said guys get on the
comments video what sort of things do
you want us to talk about what do you
want matt to talk about um is there
anything else that you would love to see
us change in the future because we're
always constantly evolving this little
channel and it's um
i'll use list of bullet points hit then
wing through that list that's that's
kind of what i do bobby i i think we'll
know each other well enough that i can
call you bobby right
probably not
um but yeah that's kind of what i do i
do bullet points you can see every so
often when i'm not sure of a fact
because i look down
and i'm like
the
37251
of the internet
because i can't sometimes i try to get i
get in my head so it looks natural but i
was just offering to see my eyes wander
down because i've got i always have
my bullet points just underneath the
camera
i'm quite bad for that i don't know if
you saw
in the last live stream we did
we we were talking about something and
there was some sort of fact
and i i i was
you were you're like you're asking me
or asking me and and stole me what
episode it was and i'm just like
on the screen
i always watch the live shows back just
to see like
how much of an idiot i look basically
and it's it's quite a lot it's quite a
big idiot
thing i have to watch them all back
again so i've actually gone to look at
some older videos and i'm like oh man
some of them
but but then every so often you just
find that little bit of gold it's like
oh that little bit of you know that
thing where we've made normally it's
because i've said something very british
that's made stormy laugh
um first time i said called somebody in
no bed that was him done for like three
or four minutes because it's just not a
thing in america
[Music]
but that's why we do isn't it because
it's fun
we have a laugh with it and that's the
main thing and hopefully i don't want to
be i don't i ever want to do a channel
that's too slick that's too sort of on
it i watch um some channels like
popcast if you've seen their guys they
they do really good videos yeah but
they're really slick
um and they they do the voiceovers with
the thing and that's very scripted
they take 20 minutes to get to the point
which really annoys me i don't i don't
really i don't really go for that sort
of thing but they do great videos they
do a lot of they you know you can see
how much hard work they put into it
and they got like 70 000 subscribers or
something
so i'm just jealous
um but you know i i don't really want to
do that sort of channel i want to do
something that's a bit more real
you know a bit raw maybe at times
and i definitely do that i do raw really
well because uh i just turn up and film
and then just like throw it out there
and see hope for the best but see what
sticks
but anyway guys so that's what we're
doing so steph i know you say you're
just a message saying you missed most of
it
matt is joining the channel he's going
to be doing videos every tuesday going
forward his first video is already up
it's set up as a premiere
um it's uh
mostly not true it's actually not true
at all but it's
my name is matt that's true
is it that it's doctor matt isn't it
it's doctor matt the physicist which is
what we agree
is it yeah
i invited you on the channel in the
first place because you're a physicist
we had this conversation last week
um
again if you're not a regular this is
just nonsense but
i just i just really really love
and i can't wait for what we're going to
be doing and
crack on matt you could talk about
whatever hell you want as long as i
agree and allow it to go on the channel
so
[Laughter]
it's a partnership
where i'm in charge
thanks very much mate i will be chatting
to you very soon i cannot wait for your
first video to premiere please everybody
set your reminders go watch this video
watch the crap out of it support matt
because he actually put did put 20 or 30
minutes worth of effort into this and no
we didn't he said literally all day was
it's friday
early
you were working on this video and and
it wasn't all day because i had to go to
work at four so
until midnight
i thought something out of christchurch
it was a horrible [ __ ] i do it every
week i hate it
i don't want to do that but yeah we need
to support this channel because we need
to get matt out of that job so there you
go and i agree harrison the funny
statement was earlier uh i suck the best
[Laughter]
and i do raw really well
don't put those two things together
they should be a t-shirt
i do raw really well
oh man i i might do i suck the best
but anyway i'm going to do a best on
video at some point where we're just
doing all
together but i just
i need the time but i you're giving me
the time i can do all these things i
wanted to do for ages instead of just
desperately trying to keep up with all
the videos i've got and the other person
i've already recorded like four videos
so now i don't have to stress
about putting them on you can take a
month off now
which is awesome
right
guys
thank you so much for joining us for
this quick little video and thank you
matt for agreeing
to join up with us and to do some videos
um and you're doing it for free so
that's even better
i didn't mention that did i
you know how i make money on this
channel we'll see how that goes
[Laughter]
and see you see you very soon say say
bye bye matthew bye-bye matthew
thanks guys see you soon i will see you
tuesday don't forget like subscribe hit
that bell notification join the channel
and make sure you support matty on his
very first video on tuesday
see you all soon
[Music]
you